you're known to be quite a good dancer
you when moved in the moment you like to
dance and you really like to go for it
we actually have a clip last year's
Super Bowl victory parade in Boston you
danced and it got pretty intense and a
little bit nasty let's take a look
[Applause]
here what's going on I don't know oh
it's fantastic
oh thank you I appreciate that yeah
that's what you know you you have to
that big win you know you you're feeling
good for for a week or two yeah just my
legs were feeling good I was busting
moves on that parade you probably danced
non-stop for a couple of weeks after you
guys why dancing I dance a lot for sure
how after last year and dancing like
that can earn you some good tips yeah
well that brings up a point I'm gonna
ask you about that because you dance a
little bit in that clip like you're a
male stripper you once accidentally did
some male stripping is that true oh yeah
that's true
how do okay I feel like I'm the princess
I'm the Dean here now this is what's
going on here mr. lawkowski did you
really did you you did some hoping once
well my boy in college
I'm always talked about how he how he
used to do these like bats bachelorette
parties I'm like well that's pretty
sweet like that sounds cool
and he's like he gets like hundreds
hundred bills at the moment right and
college and we're like that's big money
so ha I finally went with him he always
talked about it and he put this cool
cowboy suit on I was kind of just like
then you're looking smooth right now so
so he was the cowboy and what was your
role I was a security guy put a full
suit on tie I went there like this yeah
like act like backup like you're too
close get your hands off him I was just
pretending like that weird saying you
weren't supposed to strip he was going
to strip and you were just gonna be
security yes I was security and then
every lady there was giving me shots
they were making me drink their beers so
I was participating I was getting a
getting wasted on the side my friend he
got he didn't drink in college so he was
always a driver too so I worked out
perfect mm-hmm and you ended up could
you end it up you ended up dancing for a
woman is that right and then there was
like 35 women around in a circle I next
thing you know I was feeling good they
started cheering for me Chaney for me
I'm like I'm like I'm good
next thing you know I they kept cheering
so I kept getting you know feeling that
more actually not I'm taking off my tie
I'm buttoning my shirt taking my pants
off I'm in my boxers only and I'm just
giving this these lap dances out to
these ladies and they're all from ages
like 25 to like 45 minutes yeah yeah it
was just hilarious and next thing you
know I got one thrown at me and
everything made like 25 bucks actually
my my friend made like enough like a
hundred bucks I was kind of disappointed
on a game like 25 but I heard you sir so
I never told him that so when he hears
that he might hit throw me some money